[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
niedrige Sirin guten Abend Fußball
Tennis Tour de France und mehr später
bei dir Christian
guten Abend und das haben wir außerdem
ein wichtiger Sieg für die Sicherheit
der Ukraine sagt Präsident selensky über
die Ergebnisse des Nato-Gipfels in
Litauen
knappe Mehrheit im EU-Parlament für ein
umstrittenes Naturschutzgesetz Landwirte
fürchten den Verlust von Anbauflächen
Blitze Donner und ein Tornado wieder
wüten heftige Gewitter über Deutschland
[Musik]
auf dem vor drei Stunden zu Ende
gegangenen NATO-Gipfel ging es auch um
unsere Sicherheit zum ersten Mal seit
kaltem Krieg formuliert das Bündnis wie
es langfristig Europas Verteidigung
organisieren will Ukraine Präsident
selenski reist ab mit
Sicherheitsgarantien der G7-Staaten auf
schnelle nato-aufnahme aber wird er
warten müssen und seine Geduld heute
auch anderswo gefragt wie uns jetzt wohl
voller Zeit
selensky wartet auf den Bundeskanzler
und wirkt angespannt der Gipfel hat ihm
keine Einladung zum NATO-Beitritt
ausgesprochen auch Scholz war gegen eine
solche Garantie stattdessen hat der
Kanzler ein militärpaket für die Ukraine
mitgebracht im Wert von fast 700
Millionen Euro in der Pressekonferenz
zieht zelensky eine gemischte
gipfelbilanz
die Ergebnisse des Gipfels sind
zufriedenstellend aber hätten wir eine
Einladung zum NATO-Beitritt bekommen
wäre der Gipfel perfekt
danach ein herzlicher Empfang für den
ukrainischen Präsidenten
es ist schön Dich bei uns zu haben der
nato-ukraine Rat wird gegründet ein
neues Gremium in dem die Ukraine
gleichberechtigtes Mitglied ist
unsere Entscheidung hat die Ukraine
näher an die Natur herumgedrückt
der Gipfel voller Symbolik die G7
Staaten geben der Ukraine zu Sicherungen
das Land bis zum NATO-Beitritt
beschützen zu wollen sprich dauerhafte
Waffenlieferungen aber die G7 Staaten
stellen keine eigenen Truppen außerdem
muss die Ukraine die Details noch mit
den einzelnen Ländern vereinbaren
[Applaus]
Sicherheitspartnerschaft die dringend
notwendig ist und die es möglich macht
dass die Staaten die das Unterzeichnen
dann im konkreten Ihre Beiträge in der
aktuellen Situation weiter präzisieren
aber das auch einbetten in eine
längerfristige Strategie auf die sich
die Ukraine dann auch verlassen kann
diese Sicherheit zu sagen scheinen den
ukrainischen Präsidenten ein wenig mit
dem Gipfel zu versöhnen
fragen wir noch mal bei MR teven nach
für uns in Vilnius Elmar durchaus
historisch was die NATO auf den Weg
bringt man will Europa langfristig
verteidigen wie sehen die Pläne aus
ja dieser Masterplan mit mehr als 4000
Seiten ist eine komplette Neuordnung der
Sicherheit in Europa das nato-gebiet
aufgeteilt in drei Zonen Nord- und Süd
und für jede Zone ist genau beschrieben
welche Fähigkeiten man haben muss um die
zu verteidigen und daraus leitet sich
eben auch ab welche Waffen welche
Munition man braucht und wie man dann
entsprechend die Rüstungsindustrie
danach ausrichten muss das geht darum am
Ende dass die Verteidigungslinie der
NATO an keiner Stelle durchbrochen
werden kann und hier gibt es eben ein
Problem mit einem schnellen
NATO-Beitritt der Ukraine niemand weiß
wie nach einem Krieg dann die Ukraine
aussieht ob sie Teil ihres Territoriums
aufgegeben hat ob sie ihr altes
Territorium zurückbekommen hat und
deshalb konnte die Nato und wollte auch
die NATO diesen Beitrittswunsch nicht
erfüllen deshalb gibt es jetzt nur
Sicherheitsgarantien selenski Schienen
damit zufrieden aber er hat bei der
Pressekonferenz auch noch gesagt dass
die Ukraine niemals Auto beitreten werde
wenn man von ihr verlangt dass sie für
einen Friedensschluss ihre Territorien
stückweise aufgibt klare Worte zum
Abschluss dieses Gipfels Elmar vielen
Dank für die Einordnung nach Vilnius der
Umgang der NATO mit der Ukraine auch
Thema bei ZDF heute live dort schildert
Ex US-General Ben Hodge ist eine Kritik
an den Gipfel Beschlüssen ab 19:30 Uhr
in unserer App und auf unseren Social
Media Kanälen jetzt nach Straßburg wo
das EU-Parlament über ein weitreichendes
und heftig umstrittenes
Naturschutzgesetz abgestimmt hat es geht
um die Renaturierung von mindestens 20%
der Land und Meeresgebiete Wälder Flüsse
und Moore sollen wieder hergestellt
werden und weniger Pestizide auf die
Felder kommen aber es gab Widerstand von
den Konservativen sie wollten ebenso wie
die Rechtsaußenparteien das Gesetz
stoppen das schaffen sie nicht aber es
war sehr knapp dieser Welt verfass
Jubel und Erleichterung auf der einen
Seite
Enttäuschung auf der anderen knapp
stimmte das Europaparlament heute für
das Gesetz zur Wiederherstellung der
Natur eine große Mehrheit des
Europäischen Parlamentes hat heute
gezeigt dass sie für Artenschutz
einstehen will und dass sie was gegen
das Artensterben tun will gegen die
Blockade der konservativen und das ist
ein richtig gutes Zeichen abgestimmt
wurde unter anderem über das Ziel 20
Prozent der europäischen Land und
Meeresfläche bis 2030 wieder
herzustellen Wälder sollen aufgeforstet
werden mehr Flüsse sollen wieder frei
fließen diese Flächen könnten
Kohlenstoffspeichern aber auch starke
Regenfälle abfangen wie in diesem
renaturierten Gebiet im belgischen
Flandern wenn wir mit der Natur
zusammenarbeiten dann können wir auch
unsere Städte Industriegebiete und
Gebäude schützen etwa vor
Überschwemmungen
die konservative Europäische Volkspartei
EVP hatte bis zuletzt gegen das Gesetz
mobil gemacht und dabei vor allem auf
die Sorge verwiesen Bauern könnten
Agrarfläche verlieren doch nicht die
Inhalt lichen Differenzen brachten den
massiven Konflikt sondern das Vorgehen
der EVP im Vorfeld verließ sie die
eigentlich üblichen Verhandlungen über
mögliche Kompromisse und stimmte am Ende
mit den Rechtspopulisten
Wahlkampf auf Kosten der Natur auf
Kosten der Bürgerinnen und Bürger auf
Kosten unserer Lebensgrundlagen zu
machen wenn die Linken keine Argumente
mehr haben dann ist die letzte Lösung
immer den anderen vorzuwerfen Populisten
oder Trumps zu sein diese Attacken
müssen aufhören
das Gesetz wird nun noch zwischen
Parlament und Mitgliedstaaten verhandelt
das ist so kurz vorm scheitern stand
zeigt wie sich die Fronten im Parlament
verhärten eine Entwicklung die wohl über
diesen Konflikt hinaus weitergeht
die CDU-Führung hat Carsten Linnemann
einstimmig zum neuen Generalsekretär
ernannt der 45-Jährige steht wie
Parteichef märz für den
Wirtschaftsflügel und folgt zunächst
kommissarisch auf den bisherigen
Generalsekretär Mario Czaja ihm war
zuletzt aus den eigenen Reihen
vorgeworfen worden zu wenig präsent in
der Öffentlichkeit zu sein
in Deutschland ist die Zahl der
Verkehrstoten im vergangenen Jahr
deutlich gestiegen sie lag aber weiter
unter dem Niveau der vor coronazeit nach
Angaben des Statistischen Bundesamtes
sind 2022 auf Deutschland Straßen
2788 Menschen bei Verkehrsunfällen ums
Leben gekommen das sind 226 mehr als im
Jahr 2021 ein Anstieg also um 9%
besorgniserregend sei der Anstieg von
Unfällen unter Alkoholeinfluss
Thema Corona für viele eine Erinnerung
an schlechte Zeiten aber immer noch gibt
es Menschen die bis heute gesundheitlich
leiden sie haben long kovet
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach warnt vor
großen Schäden für die Wirtschaft er
will die long kovid-forschung fördern
und Betroffenen besser helfen Heike
slanski berichtet
seit zwei Jahren kämpft Jeanette Erdmann
gegen die Folgen einer Kuh wird
Infektion Kurzatmigkeit Muskelschmerzen
chronische Erschöpfung Symptome die in
unregelmäßigen Abständen auftreten die
Ärzte oft ratlos hinterlassen die
Symptome kommen Intervallen manchmal
sind manchmal stärker manchmal sind sie
ganz weg um danach ein paar Wochen
wieder aufzutreten manche Symptome sind
gänzlich weg die Haarausfall z.B oder
auch dieses starken Herzbeschwerden
andere kommen wieder hinzu wie die
Temperaturempfindlichkeit
also es ist wirklich wie ein Kameleon
was ständig wieder neue Sachen erfindet
viele lungenkow wird betroffene fühlen
sich im Stich gelassen der
Gesundheitsminister bietet nun eine neue
Webseite an mit Informationen für
erkrankte und Ärzte für die Menschen mit
long Kove
in Deutschland das Problem dass es
spitzenversorgung gibt wie zum Beispiel
in der Charité oder in Hamburg aber die
flächendeckende Versorgung die ist
natürlich bei weitem nicht da wo sie
sagen muss um nach geeigneten Therapien
zu forschen will Lauterbach 40 Millionen
Euro zur Verfügung stellen ursprünglich
waren mal 100 Millionen angekündigt noch
gibt es keine Aussicht auf Heilung in
der Vergangenheit wurden diese
postinfektiösen Erkrankung gerade in
Deutschland oft als psychisch eingestuft
als psychosomatisch und auch falsch
behandelt und dieses Wissen sitzt tief
schätzungsweise 2,5 Millionen mit
Langzeitfolgen die meisten immer noch
ohne adäquate Grundversorgung
der brandenburgische Verfassungsschutz
hat die afd-jugend Organisation junge
Alternative als gesichert
rechtsextremistische Bestrebung
eingestuft die Behörde wirft dem AFD
Nachwuchs eine ideologische Nähe zum
Nationalsozialismus vor außerdem würden
gezielt Vorurteile gegen vermeintlich
Fremde geschirrt die brandenburgische
afd-chefin kündigte juristische Schritte
an
die hohe Zustimmung zu rechten
Positionen im Osten Deutschlands hatte
vor zwei Wochen eine Studie der Uni
Leipzig dokumentiert dass die Zahlen in
Sachsen-Anhalt besonders alarmierend
waren damit haben sich Wissenschaftler
Gewerkschaftler und Bürgerinitiativen
heute noch einmal beschäftigt
11,6 Prozent der Bevölkerung in
Sachsen-Anhalt haben einen geschlossenes
rechtsextremes Weltbild deutlich mehr
als im Durchschnitt der ostdeutschen
Bundesländer gleichzeitig ist gerade mal
ein Drittel mit der Demokratie im Alltag
zufrieden neue Strategien sein notwendig
so der Appell heute in Magdeburg Hagen
Nicolas
Plakate mit eigenen Wünschen und Zielen
gestalten spielerisch sollen Kinder und
Jugendliche im Jugendclub Gardelegen so
die demokratische Teilhabe lernen was
ich mir wünsche ist einen großen Garten
weil ich bin so eine kleine
pflanzenliebhaberin dann natürlich
vielleicht mal irgendwann eine schöne
Beziehung Selbstwirksamkeit
zu erleben sich selbst in der Position
zu begeben wo ich mit entscheide selbst
was mache Verantwortung übernehme das
ist für uns demokratiebildung und ganz
wichtig viele Sachsen-Anhalter sind
derzeit unzufrieden mit der Demokratie
die Gründe sind unterschiedlich weil ich
denke dass an den Wünschen und
Bedürfnissen und den Notwendigkeiten
vorbei regiert wird vielleicht das viele
Versprechungen Anfang gemacht werden und
kaum welche umgesetzt werden das deshalb
vielleicht die Unzufriedenheit vorrangig
da ist als Ursachen gelten die geringe
parteienbindung die Folgen der
Wiedervereinigung außerdem fehlen die
Erfahrung auf wichtige Entscheidung ein
rausnehmen zu können sagen Forscher der
Hochschule Magdeburg Stendal dass man
sich selber nicht wahrgenommen fühlt
dass man im Alltag das heißt in den
Betrieben in der Schule auch im Studium
nicht die Erfahrung macht dass man sein
Umfeld aktiv mitgestalten kann zu
gründen für die verbreitete
rechtsextremen Einstellungen sei weitere
Forschung nötig beim Umgang mit der AFD
empfehlen die Forscher pragmatische
Lösungen ohne Ausgrenzung aber mit klar
definierten Grenzen indem man klar sagt
einer Interaktion mit der AFD kann man
nicht aus dem Weg gehen
aber das bedeutet auch dass es keine
Kooperation geben kann und geben darf
Wünsche formulieren und Kompromisse
finden wichtig für die Demokratie bei
der Aktionswoche im Jugendclub üben sie
das noch spielerisch
der Nachthimmel über Deutschland so sah
es gestern Abend dann vielen Orten im
Westen und Süden aus Wetterleuchten
Vorboten Heranziehen der Gewitter die
entlohnen sich in Baden-Württemberg
Bayern und im Saarland mit heftigen
Stürmen mehrere Menschen wurden verletzt
und im Saarland da traf das Unwetter
einen Ort besonders schwer antoniani
die Gewitterfront mit Starkregen und
orkanartigen Windböen hält die
Rettungskräfte in Atem das Dach eines
Hauses einfach weggeweht im
saarländischen Freisen deckt der Organ
in wenigen Minuten ganze Dächer ab ein
Augenzeuge dann kam a-Moll der Sturm
sehe 50 Sekunden ja und da muss
machbar sei Dach alles weggeflogen ist
alles die Rettungskräfte kommen kaum
hinterher sie müssen Menschen retten
Straßen Freiräumen Keller leer pumpen
deswegen 17:45 Uhr ein Tornado durch den
Ortsteil durchgerast paar zahlreiche
Dächer abgedeckt verletzte Personen gibt
es zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt noch nicht der
Sachschaden im Saarland geht in die
Millionen auch in Baden-Württemberg
sorgen Gewitterzellen für Chaos auf der
A8 stürzt eine ungeknickte Baum auf
einen Reisebus der von Ulmen Richtung
Stuttgart unterwegs war zum Glück ohne
Fahrgäste verletzt wird niemand und
nicht weit entfernt steht in Ulm ein
Haus in Flammen eine Blitzeinschlag ist
die Dämmung des Dachstuhls in Brand
geraten aktuell decken wir das Dach ab
mit Spezialkräften der
höhenrettungseinheit die unwetterfron
zieht weiter über Teile Bayerns Bäume
knicken blockieren bahnleitungen
vielerorts auch in München bleiben am
Morgen die Bahnen stehen die auf
zusammenarbeiten nach der Gewitternacht
dauern den ganzen Tag
die frühere Ministerpräsidentin von
Schleswig-Holstein Heide Simones ist tot
die 80-Jährige war Deutschlands erste
Landeschefin und regierte das
nördlichste Bundesland bis 2005 ihre
politische Karriere endete spektakulär
vor einigen Jahren machte die
SPD-Politikerin ihre
Parkinson-Erkrankung öffentlich und zog
sich dann immer mehr zurück Tim Krüger
erinnert
eine vollblutpolitikerin war sie die das
Rampenlicht suchte die Popularität
genossen eine steile Karriere machte
2005 aber das hier Ende nach der
Landtagswahlen Schleswig-Holstein
verweigert ihr ein Unbekannter
Abgeordneter aus den eigenen Reihen die
Gefolgschaft bei der Wahl zum
Ministerpräsidentin Heide Simones den
Tränen nach nach zwölf Jahren als
Ministerpräsidentin Abschied von
Parteiämtern und Politik
ich war immer gerne mit dabei
leidenschaftlich mit dabei und ich finde
es hat sich gelohnt
1969 tritt sie in die SPD ein im
Bundestag macht sie schnell als
finanzpolitisches Nachwuchstalent auf
sich aufmerksam und der
Ministerpräsident björn Engholm wird sie
Finanzministerin in Schleswig-Holstein
1993 beerbte ihn als er im Zug der
Barsche Affäre zurücktreten muss Heide
Simones wird die erste
Ministerpräsidentin der Bundesrepublik
wieder einmal hat sie sich in der
Männerwelt durchgesetzt ich habe
wirklich in der männerdominierten Welt
angefangen und habe auch immer nur
Bereiche gemacht die von Männern
dominiert war und der Hinweis ich bin
doch so kleines zartes Mädchen und komme
aus dem hohen Norden hätte die zum
Lachen vor Freude also das war's denn
wohl nicht also dann lernt man das
relativ schnell und dann arbeitet man an
bestimmten Stellen wo es drauf ankommt
genauso wie diese männerregel um einen
herum auch nach ihrer politischen
Karriere ging es turbulent weiter als
Vorsitzende von UNICEF Deutschland trat
sie im Zuge der Affäre und
Provisionszahlungen an Spenden Eingabe
zurück
mit Heide Simones hat die Bundesrepublik
eine der leidenschaftlichsten
beliebtesten aber auch streitbarsten
Politiker Persönlichkeiten überhaupt
verloren
er war reforma Dissident Literat jetzt
ist der französisch-tschechische
Schriftsteller Milan kunderer gestorben
mit 94 Jahren in Paris Welt berühmt
machte in der Roman die unerträgliche
Leichtigkeit des Seins bis zuletzt blieb
kunderas Verhältnis zu seiner
heimatschwierig Volker Duczek zum Tode
eines großen Schriftstellers und
Europäers
die Milan kunderer Bibliothek in Brünn
im April hat der Schriftsteller sie
seiner tschechischen Geburtsstadt
geschenkt ein Symbol für die Heimkehr
von Milan kunderer in jahrzehntelang
hatte sich der gebürtige Tschechien mit
seinem Heimatland überworfen ein
bewegtes Leben
er gilt als der bedeutendste
Schriftsteller seiner Generation
übersetzt den mehr als 40 Sprachen 1984
erscheint die unerträgliche Leichtigkeit
des Seins ein Buch das auch als
Filmforen macht mit den beiden
Hauptdarstellern Juliette Pinos und
Daniel day Lewis eine Liebesgeschichte
mit viel Sinn für Erotik vor und nach
dem Prager Frühling die 60er Jahre wie
viele seiner Generation tritt Kunde rein
die Kommunistische Partei ein und wird
zum prominentenvertreter der
Demokratiebewegung Prager Frühling die
Desillusionierung folgt schnell im
August 1968 ist der Prager Frühling
schon wieder beendet mit dem Einmarsch
der sowjetischen Truppen kunderer
verliert seine Stelle an der Universität
seine Bücher werden nicht mehr verlegt
1975 Exil in Frankreich schreibt nur
noch in Französisch verbietet lange Zeit
Übersetzung in seine Muttersprache 2019
nimmt kunderer wieder die tschechische
Staatsbürgerschaft an die in die
kommunistische Regierung entsorgen hatte
die später Versöhnung nach 40 Jahren
bei uns geht es jetzt sportlich weiter
Christian die deutschen Fußballerinnen
sind auf dem Weg zur WM nach Australien
Neuseeland aber Ziel Australien müssten
noch in der Luft sein ja aber ich denke
sie sitzen sehr sehr bequem so gegen 22
Uhr wird die Mannschaft von
Bundestrainerin Martina fast Tecklenburg
in Sydney landen voller Vorfreude auf
das Turnier und mit dem Wunsch um den
Titel zu spielen der Tenor endlich
geht's los dass wir im Gefühl kann
kommen
lange Reise klares Ziel für ein paar
Vorrundenspiele will keiner um die halbe
Welt fliegen
ich bin sechs Wochen von daher großer
und kleiner Koffer gepackt
das ist dabei und es ja soll möglichst
lange gehen wir würden wenn wir die
Qualität nicht in der Mannschaft hätten
nicht klar auch sagen dass wir um den
Titel spielen wollen und die Qualität
ist voll vorhanden im Kader daran gab es
zuletzt Zweifel etwa nach dem verlorenen
Test gegen Sambia der Turnier Fahrplan
soll deshalb aber nicht durcheinander
kommen
wir ziehen unsere Lehrerin immer aus
jedem Spiel versuchen die Dinge im
nächsten Spiel besser zu machen streben
in erster Linie mal den Gruppensieg an
einen ganzen Tag dauert die Reise nach
Sydney
genügend Zeit sich mit den Zielen im
Gepäck weiter anzufreunden
vierte Medaille für die deutsche
Mannschaft bei den
para-weltmeisterschaften in der
Leichtathletik Nico Kappel gewann in
Paris mit 14 Meter 49 Silber im
Kugelstoßen der kleinwüchsigen Gold ging
an den Usbeken immer noch der 24 cm
weiter stieß
die WM Teilnahme von Weitsprung
Olympiasiegerin Malaika mir Hamburg in
fünf Wochen in Budapest ist gefährdet
ihre oberschenkelverletzungen die sie am
Sonntag bei den Deutschen
Meisterschaften in Kassel erlitt ist ein
kleiner Muskelfaserriss bedeutet drei
Wochen ruhigeres Training und sie werden
nur zur Titelverteidigung antreten wenn
Sie eine medaille-chance hat so die
29-Jährige
11 etappe der Tour de France zum dritten
Mal unter den Top 3 Phil Bauhaus er
wurde Dritter hinter Jasper Philipsen
Belgien und dem Niederländer Dillen
Gröne wegen an der Spitze der
Gesamtwertung gab es keine Veränderung
und noch zum Tennis in Wimbledon dort
steht das deutsche Doppel Kevin Krawitz
timpitz im Halbfinale
bei den French Open unter den besten 8
und den bündelten nun sogar im
Halbfinale Kevin Krawitz und Tim Pütz
beim Ballwechsel hinten im Bild gelang
gegen den Briten Jamie Mary und Michael
Wien ist aus Neuseeland jeweils ein
Break pro Satz und nach 80 Minuten
beendete Krawitz das Match mit einem Ass
zum 6 zu 4 und 6:3 Erfolg für das
deutsche Davis Cup Doppel dem jetzt nur
noch zwei Siege zum Wimbledon Titel
fehlen
bei den Frauen ist nun auch im
doppel-laura Siegemund raus als letzte
deutsche nur noch die beiden Männer
dabei danke Christin trotzdem haben wir
zum Schluss noch eine runde Sache für
Sie Las Vegas bekannt für Glücksspiel
und unglaubliche Shows ist jetzt um eine
Attraktion reicher eine gigantische
Kuppel mit dem Namen des vier zieht
viele Blicke auf sich die wird als
atemberaubend beschrieben und ist mit
einer Fläche von rund 54
000 Quadratmetern das größte LED Display
der Welt hauptsächlich sollen hier
Sportveranstaltung und Konzerte
stattfinden offiziell eröffnet wird die
höchste kugelkonstruktion der Welt Ende
September mit einem Konzert von YouTube
große Bilder vielen jetzt noch die
Lottozahlen die gehen so zwei sieben
neun neun zehn 21 30 die Superzahl
lautet 2 weitere Gewinnzahlen auf
lotto.zdf.de und auf der ZDF Text Seite
ja auch heute Abend kann es noch
kräftige Gewitter geben wo erfahren Sie
gleich von Katja horneffer zum heute
journal erwartet Sie auch heute Maria
das lomka ab 21:45 Uhr danke und noch
einen schönen Abend für Sie
[Musik]
guten Abend das waren ja wirklich
heftige Gewitter die da in den
vergangenen 24 Stunden über uns
hinweggezogen sind der zirrenschirm
hatte einen Durchmesser von mehreren 100
km von diesem Gewitter Cluster weitere
Gewitter zogen hier über die Alpen und
am Nachmittag entwickelten sich im
Alpenvorland neue Regenschauer und
Gewitter zogen auch von der Nordsee zu
uns sein und das ganze bei Westwind so
wurde die schwule Hitze aus Deutschland
weggeräumt und sie werden heute Nacht
gut lüften können denn die Temperaturen
sinken Meister 15 bis 10 Grad nur in
Sachsen Bayern unter dem Oberrhein
bleibt es etwas milder auch heute Nacht
gibt's noch kräftige Schauer zum Teil
auch mal längeren Regen hier in
Süddeutschland auch in Nordwesten sind
Schauer und Gewitter unterwegs sonst
bleibt es aber trocken und das macht
sich auch bei der Waldbrandgefahr
bemerkbar denn die ist doch immer sehr
hoch hier im Nordosten im Nordwesten und
dem Süden dagegen hat der Regen eine
kleine Verschnaufpause gebracht und auch
morgen regnet es dort noch etwas weiter
es gibt noch Schauer und Gewitter im
Süden und auch im Nordwesten bleibt das
unbeständig Leute freundlicher ist es
von Berlin Brandenburg bis zum Mittel
und zum Oberrhein bei Westwind und so
liegen die Temperaturen bei 19 bis 28
Grad der Freitag wird freundlich aber
schon am Samstag drohen von Westen neue
Unwetter guten Abend